it's almost thanksgiving and while we
all love coming together around the
table
things can get a little heated and we've
got two guests here who can get a little
competitive over their cornbread
stuffing and they're gonna settle this
debate once and for all right here in
thanksgiving dish off
please welcome antoinette bond and her
mother-in-law gloria bond
hello bond ladies hello we're bond girls
yeah you are bond girls it's about time
we got a bond girl
i love it um when did this feud start
tell me all about it
well the way this all started was my
mother-in-law owns christmas
and so once i got married to her son
about 28 years ago then that's when i
realized like wait a minute what am i
going to own and i made the conscious
decision that i'm owning thanksgiving
and i'm going to be the best cook the
best stuffing maker that's possible and
that's when it started getting like hey
i can cook and i'm going to take her
down
[Applause]
gloria what do you think about all this
talk and uh i think she's better be
careful before
before i whisper in my son's ear
and tell him
well
let's talk stuffing okay now the stakes
are high okay and the winner's gonna get
a trophy
[Applause]
and
the loser is gonna have to do dishes not
only this thanksgiving but for the next
five years oh okay
i'm so excited thank you for doing this
with me oh thank you guys
all right
let's find out who will win at the end
of the show but we're all winners
because we get to watch you do this i
want to check in and see how mother and
daughter-in-law antoinette and gloria
are doing over the kitchen
now
what's it like on thanksgiving day
ladies are you both cooking is there
football happening like is it all the
cliches or do you have your own
traditions because i love all of it oh
we are very big a sports family so we
are like cooking in the morning and then
by by the time like the dallas cowboys
they always started off with the first
game so by the time they come on we're
ready to watch football and we eat
actually twice on thanksgiving one time
like lunch time and then we're ready for
our second time at night you know what i
actually really love that because
everybody's hungry by one or two and
then they start snacking and that whole
like we're gonna eat at six i'm like are
you kidding me exactly and then take a
nap yeah exactly you eat lunch doze off
and then eat dinner all right well this
is excellent we're going to keep
checking in with you throughout the show
because we are doing a stuffing contest
and i am here for this i'm going to be
the winner okay i love it i love it
and it's time for the dish reveal rossy
ross and i are excited to get tasted yes
we love stuffing around here and you
guys it smells like thanksgiving in here
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
okay oh gosh okay antoinette um tell us
about your dish please
okay so mine is a family we passed down
from my grandmother to my mom so this
has been a recipe on my family for
probably like 70 years and so i
combined what makes mine special is
putting real bits of turkey into the
actual dressing and so i'm combining all
the flavors you got to make sure you're
doing the right sauteing you get that
done and then blah boom that's what you
get oh my god
[Applause]
just when i thought i knew stuffing i
this is blowing me away all right it's
the little chunks of turkey in there
it's like a creaminess i'm not used to
right it's a texture
almost like a like a stuffing pudding
yeah basically yeah
oh dear okay
so excited to try your stuffing i'd love
to get a plate as fast as possible
okay
and ask you about what your methodology
is oh thank you rossi
um what is your stuffing technique
what's your secret
my secret
is no eggs in my stuffing really eggs
and why is that may i eggs
makes the stuffing packy
heavy mmm oh my god oil makes it light
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
just
when i thought i knew stuffing
you changed the game again on
[Music]
uh me rossi i um as uh out of respect um
for a mother-in-law i and a daughter i
don't want to get in the middle of this
one so i think we need a little help
making our decision i have a surprise
for you both oh i have someone else
who's uh coming in to taste please
welcome gloria's husband
[Applause]
i don't want to get in the middle of
this i just thought i would put your
husband and son
you know we did
[Applause]
walter you are one strong man to show up
to this
get yourself in the middle of it and let
me say that these both of these
beautiful women contributed to this
they built this together they could say
that
they tag team this right
um
okay so
walter
i mean
ross i know since drew and i can't
really make the call um are you ready to
taste let's go let's do it okay let's
start down here this
is gosh this is going to be a rough
thanksgiving yeah i am so
i don't know what they're doing
i am so excited for you walter to be in
the hot seat right now not me i am but
that said um this is a win-win situation
well they say happy
wife happy life right
but but
you only get one mama
you're a smart man diplomacy it always
wins
delicious okay so great delicious okay
now we got to try mama's mama
all right we call it big mama at home
okay okay big mom i love you mama i love
you guys
i got to go home with her but i like it
there's the back door out of here
i need a
[Applause]
can we talk to the audience at home
[Applause]
well i declared a draw
[Applause]
so guess what
you'll share the trophy
[Applause]
we found your centerpiece this year
exactly
that can go right on your thanksgiving
table
you guys stick together you can go right
on your thanksgiving table
thank you antoinette and gloria and
walter seriously thank you
[Music]